sans much trumpeted decision in 2016 to
produce the x-trail in Sunderland was
hailed as a sign that brexit Britain was
open for business
last week just as the EU Japan free
trade deal came into force Nissan went
into shuddering reverse the x-trail
would not be made in Britain but Japan
no deal brexit ears are protesting this
has nothing to do with brexit despite
Nissan part blaming brexit for its
decision even though the house
economists of brexit Patrick Minford has
admitted that brexit will run down the
automotive industry which supports
800,000 jobs and contributes over 80
billion to the economy Nissan is only in
the UK because we are worth in the EU
the Gateway to the largest single market
in the world which we are leaving leave
means leave for Nissan Jaguar Land Rover
Dyson Airbus Sony Panasonic all voting
with their feet it's close to midnight
now this is not project fear this is
Project Reality time to slam on the
brakes and stop this industrial crash
out
wrecking Britain Rachel you don't know
anything about the motor industry so I'm
not surprised you've got this wrong
you're partly right this breaks it of
course
diesel down the EU Japan deal which
means it's easier to sell cars in so
you're aware of the diesel downturn
you're aware of the scrapping where 30%
down Diesel's okay you're aware that
also as you rightly said Jaguar Land
Rover Ford they're brought scaling down
production you're aware that China even
China not buying as many cars you're
aware of all of that that the global
market consumption of diesel cars is a
sump in China but that you choose just
okay just slow down can I just point out
one thing the Jaguar Land Rover
and and slowdowns in the other brands
are slated for after March this year in
presumption that there are going to be
autumn
you're right if you're right I chained
difficult after praxis I think as I said
I think it's partly to blame five
minutes to midnight and we're all doomed
and God knows when I'd like to show you
a picture of a car I'll show you a
picture but it's not my car this is a
Toyota Corolla now a couple of weeks ago
Toyota began production of the all-new
Corolla hatchback and the state range at
its manufacturing facility in Derbyshire
Corolla is the world's best-selling car
across the whole of the planet the
Derbyshire Factory employs three
thousand people and it received 240
million in investment last year Toyota
the best-selling car the work is being
built in Derbyshire if you were right I
wouldn't have been able to say what I
just said
are they intending to send those
Corollas outside the UK you think
they're gonna buy every single broker I
don't know what their intentions they
will be exporting tonight so you like to
withdraw your point bring in can we
broaden when the panel comes in can we
broaden it beyond the car industry
because we have seen a slight brexit us
of business and it's not because brexit
hasn't happened yet it's because in fear
that we will not get a deal I think that
if we get a deal I think there is 60%
chance Theresa May will get her deal
through and we will stay in the customs
union my point if I'm in five minutes to
midnight is that companies have to press
the button on their investments dishes
decisions now and we've seen this
happening I will take the new sound
point on the chin all right if it was
for the fact that this and we're gonna
move out and go to France say but
they're not that I can all ride back to
Japan now taking this on a wider field
I've got a friend who's developing a
drinks business it's doing the extremely
well he's turning over 15 million plus
cans or whatever is he's doing I yeah he
can't wait for those boards to come down
so he can do deals all over the place
okay and pumped out far more cans and
what you would have been able to if he
was part of the European Union right so
he wants to sell his drink to calm down
in the 17% of the world that pretty
far-flung outside the EU that he thinks
it's going to be easier to trade with it
just a bit confused because when you say
borders coming down I don't know if
we've got complete
Shane is is he's going to be less
restricted in his movement selling
drinks as part of the into Japan he'd be
much easier for him if we stayed in the
EU because now we've got a free trade
deal with Japan it's completely right
whether you whether you I think we all
acknowledge that breaks that is not the
only factor affecting business but if
you are a government in a climate where
there are slowdowns there's
globalization there's automation that
are threatening your manufacturing
sector you don't then go about creating
the most difficult hostile and
unpredictable business imaginable I'm
gonna pay you what the conservative
business secretary says about this
because even he acknowledges that things
are looking bad as appointed that the
new jobs associated with the x-trail
will not now come to Sunderland I'm
pleased that the plant would benefit
from substantial new investment in the
existing models and that the decision to
continue with the vital investment in
the Qashqai leaf and Juke and the jobs
associated with them is unaffected
those jobs are unaffected but the 714
new jobs that would have been created by
the x-trail will now not be created in
Sunderland because of this the reality
is you know we can all we've all got a
views on bricks that remain why are we
not listening to what businesses say is
good it's not good for business and
everyone knows that I really disagree
with you and I really feel what I feel
yeah everything in our episode
now on this particular issue I feel very
strongly about this I feel very strongly
that brexit know you always do this when
as soon as I open my mouth you do listen
it annoys me I feel very strongly that
brixi is being constantly you as an it
started Rachel it started in July 2016
when Lloyds announced a business
transformation program
said that there was closing shops and
making redundancies a month after the
vert now I have ran and worked on and
been part of significant business
transformation programs that run into
their multi millions and span years a
business for them to evolve and
transform they do sir it's normally a
very concerted process profit if they're
honest profit is normally at the heart
of it structuring restructuring etc but
it's normally got a profit motive now
what happens when businesses decide to
restructure is brexit has become almost
a fashionable excuse it's become a
fashionable excuse for people for
businesses not to face up differently if
you were in international multinational
company now that was based in the UK
that depended on just-in-time supply
chains yeah what and you had you could
headquarter let's say in Amsterdam yeah
wouldn't you be thinking about head
coaching in Amsterdam simply because you
don't see those just-in-time supply
chains whereas you won't necessarily if
we do leave without to do up there two
things to that first of all the
uncertainty point since the uncertainty
that we that we have at the moment is
absolutely terrible and it is that
uncertainty which makes it difficult for
a business to plan so that's a first
point the second point is just in time
Manufacturing is just one form of
manufacturing by the way there are many
other ones yes a lot of these
manufacturers depend on apart arriving
and then two hours later happen again is
not in time Manufacturing we don't see
your resume we have interruptions to
traffic and paper inter alia briefly if
the eurozone is so fantastic why is it
teetering on the edge of recession Italy
is in referring in recession France is
virtually there the eurozone it was
reported this week is on the verge of
recession was in recession why are
people appearing the EU Japan trade deal
does not smell good if it is so great
how come they've got to fall into
recession I'm
we should go into the in the EU
come on we were part of the we are not
in the euro though didn't know but they
are about if it is so fantastic with
this EU train room by the way I have
said I have said I have said so many
times it's probably not the right time
to do it but it's the right thing to do
because the EU is not cannot continue it
is why would they be go into recession
why if it's so great why so are you
thinking how many years also why dissing
the EU it would not remember the EU
because it but if it was a bit with the
beer or whatever is oh we've got this
Marvis trade in Europe if it's so
marvellous is in recession because of
all the reasons you mentioned the global
slowdown China trade conditions are
difficult Trump and tariff climate for
global trade our response is to do
everything our businesses how does that
make thing all right it might not be
that it's a project that's had its day
it might not be there why can